so science of great user interfaces and
great design we're going to talk about
this very quickly I have collected some
of my favorite guidelines that's me
right there where it might see my super
cool superhero look over there my emails
in the bottom left and my Twitter
handles there as well Miller mark on
Twitter I've been writing developer
productivity tools for about 30 years
I've been researching great design for
about half of that time about 16 years
now and I'm chief scientist for the IDE
tools team at DevExpress the product
that I spend most of my time working on
is code rush for Visual Studio so that's
a little bit about me here's what we're
gonna hit and I think we're gonna hit
these things pretty quickly we're going
to talk about emphasis and importance
contrast and readability proximity and
layout borders and spacing and fill and
corners so emphasis of importance first
so emphasis is the ability to make
information appear important and here
are some of the ways that we can do this
right so it's to some degree you could
look at this and say well I can see that
one way I could characterize this as
saying well most of the text is
reference is rendered in one way but
portion of it is rendered a different
way so that's one of the ways that we
can do it is just by being different and
we can also do things with contrast
saturation shadow that sort of thing so
emphasis is the ability to make it
information appear important keep this
in mind as we move forward now I know
some things about some superheroes I
know about bad girl I know about the
Hulk I know about Scarlet Witch and I
know about Superman all right I know
about their powers and I know about
their secret identities and you know
about their chances of beating me in a
battle and let's organize the
information that we know so I'll create
a table and we'll put some columns
headers here for the information we'll
put the bad girl here
secret identity Barbara Gordon chances
of beating me in a fight 100% The Hulk
main powers Hulk smash
secret identity Bruce Banner chance of
beating me to find about 50% if I catch
him on an on Hulk day and I sneak up
Scarlet Witch and there's Superman so
this is the information that we have
here when we're talking about the things
that I know but the question here is can
we separate this presentation into two
different groups of information one of
the groups the high importance data and
one of the other groups the low
importance data I don't want to give you
a second to look at this and think about
that question how do we separate this
information into two different groups
and here's what I did if you're looking
at the text and thinking well which
parts of the text are important and
which ones are not then you're missing a
really important concept and the
important concept is that everything on
screen is information even the borders
right even the background everything on
screen in an interesting presentation is
is information and so the question is
what's important and what's not is a
good question to ask the reason why well
we'll take a look at as we move forward
here you'll see it in a second
everything here in this table if we zoom
in on it and go in even closer notice
that the width of the border lines is
equal to the width of the font stroke
also notice that the contrast is the
same as well for both of these the
contrast between the line or the text
font and the text and its background is
the same it's black on white so in this
presentation that we have here the
emphasis is the same everywhere
experiment we might take the border
lines and say well let's really
emphasize those will use two techniques
we'll use will you keep a stick in the
high contrast and we'll make them even
bigger
and let's DM ffice eyes the other
information which we identified is
important by making it a little bit
lighter and lower in contrast and
continuing the experience in experiment
in the opposite direction we can create
a table where emphasis matches
importance and then we can take a look
at these three and ask ourselves a
question which one of these three is
easier to read the data and if you're
like virtually everyone you're gonna say
the answer is this table down here right
and in this table emphasis matches
importance so earlier we said that
emphasis is a way of making the brain
think that information is more important
and and we also said that everything on
screen is information well
now what we can do is we can use this
guideline emphasis matches importance to
create things that our presentations
they're easier to read so that's
guideline number one here's an example
right here I'm playing Yahtzee with the
kids we roll the dice out on a brown
brown dice on a brown table and I'm like
wait what in low light and I'm like what
did I roll a better fix to this would be
create dice that have high emphasis such
as this the high contrast on the
important information contrast and
readability so I've got a question here
this slide asks the question does this
text seem hard to read on top and on the
bottom it asked the question does this
text seem easy to read and again if
you're like most people the answer is
yeah the text on the top seems harder to
read and the text on the bottom does
seem significantly easier to read and
the question is why if we extract the
saturation remove the saturation from
this presentation you'll start to see
something kind of interesting the text
on top is well it's still there but it's
perceived brightness is essentially
equal to the brightness of the
background
the takeaway here is that we're not
reading in color we're reading
essentially in black and white on the
perceived brightness spectrum and what
that means the implication of this is is
that text needs to be high contrast in
order to be easy to read sufficient
contrast from the background on the
black and white spectrum so you want to
stink text from the background in black
and white
the next guideline proximity and layout
actually I think I may have a couple
things in here the first concept is
friends enemies and others and so I've
got a photo album here and I've got some
pictures of some cute puppies and I just
want to organize them in my photo album
so I'm gonna put this one up here and
then I'm gonna take another look at a
NYX photo and I'm gonna say okay where
should I put that and if you're like
most people intuitively we're like well
let's put it with the other one so okay
we'll move that over there and let's
look at another photo Oh more cute
puppies okay we'll put that right here
and then we'll take a look at another
one of the photos I've got at all does
it go over here or does it feel better
over here and then if I've got this
picture of a house does it go with the
puppies does it go with the cat or does
it maybe go right here kind of an
interesting example but it's to
illustrate a point that friends
information that is contextually related
feels better and is more readily
digested and understood when that
information is closed to other friends
and similarly it's more easily
understood with as far away from the
enemies so that's what we want to do and
we're looking at information we want to
identify friends or closely contextually
related pieces of information and we
want to identify enemies as well here's
an example in real life which button do
i press to go to the 30th floor I'll let
you think about that for a little bit
and maybe you're thinking okay mark
that's not fair you zoomed in really
close right I want to see more I'm like
okay but you know if you were blind you
just get what your fingers were touching
this would be it but
give you more here's more which button
do i press to get to the 30th floor and
now I think you may be starting to see
the problem right one of these buttons
is a friend of the label that's next to
it and one of these buttons is an enemy
to the label that is on its other side
right in other words the button to the
30th floor is the enemy of the 29th on
the floor label and yet they're
equidistant apart it's what I call a
proximity violation alright so we want
to follow that guideline here's another
example which way to Fort Worth right
and here's an example where the enemies
are close to the friends right so Fort
Worth the arrow pointing to the left
that's not Fort Worth that's for Justin
in fact how many people do want to bet
came to the sign and they turned the
wrong way because that arrow pointing to
the left is so close to Fort Worth yeah
Jeff neck out there in the chat room who
says Jesus we couldn't figure that out a
couple ways to fix it one is to follow
the proximity guidelines put the friends
close together so put fort worth text
next to its arrow here's another way to
do the same thing here's another way we
could do it where we could keep things
in the same place but use a background
color change to indicate which how our
friends are contextually grouped
together or we could use a line a border
line how do all of these the one in the
upper left is my favorite because it's
scalable for multiple cities and
requires really no changes to any of the
printing mechanics for creating these
sites so there's the original and
there's our fix over on the right so
friends close enemies apart these are
the proximity guidelines borders and
spacing so I had this question a few
years ago the question is well I've got
my text and I want to put a border
around it but where do I put it I
couldn't find any guidelines for this
out in the real world and based on
my research I still think there's
nothing out there that describes the
answer this question also I'll show you
what I came up with and this is based on
a fair amount of research including
research in the way we recognize and
understand the letters and actually the
parts of the letters those come from
something called the feature detectors
in our brains so when I say the parts of
the letters I mean the crosses and the
curves and the endpoints and here's what
I came up with well actually before I
show you that I'll just clearly show you
extremes right sometimes I'll go to
extremes when I'm researching a problem
here's an extreme right here where it
just simply it looks and feels too far
away
and here's another extreme where it just
looks and feels too close so we know the
answer is between these two here's what
I came up with I take the distance of
the space the width of the space between
two letters and I multiply that by 1.5
and I simply add that to the sides
excuse me and I also add that up to the
tops and bottoms as well and that is the
answer to the question it's far enough
away that our letter detectors won't
because what ever confuse it for a
potentially another letter next to the
ending letters of the text or the
beginning letters of the text it's far
enough away so we won't confuse that
which means our cognitive load is down
which means it's easier to read okay but
it's not too far away right so it's just
in there this nice nice close distance
now there are ways to get it even closer
for example if I change the contrast of
the line notice I've still got it the
same thickness this line is as thick as
the stroke width of the fonts I can
bring it in closer I can also change the
thickness I can maintain the same
contrast and just make it super thin or
to both make it both lighter
in contrast lower contrast and make it
better if I need to really get in tight
so those are two different ways to get
to kind of violate that rule so when I
do this presentation print opal live
audience I'm off and I'll bring this
slide up and I'll say hey what do you
which you prefer the one on the left or
the one on the right and virtually
everybody says the one on the right I
say okay
would you prefer here just doing our a
be testing everybody says the right and
I'm like which one do you prefer here
and around here about 97% of the folks
in the room 95 to 97% say the one on the
right still and the takeaway here is
that the the guideline for borders is
that they should be thin and low
contrast call it an example with the
border I've actually seen real examples
of borders on real websites and other UI
that have a thick high contrast border
that's incorrect that's the one on the
right sorry the one on the right is the
way to do it Phil and corners so I've
got two stars in the middle of the
screen and the question here is which
star looks bigger the one on the left or
the one on the right and if you are if
you're like most people you're gonna say
the one on the right looks bigger in
reality they actually are constrained by
the same bounding boxes but the one on
the right has got rounded corners and as
a result has about thirty four thirty
five percent almost more pixels than the
one on the left the the takeaway here is
that if you want icons to be easier to
see and you're constrained by it by the
size of the Occident icon like in a
particular box like sixteen by sixteen
use rounded corners for the icons
salience so salience is a really kind of
interesting topic and the idea of
salience is what does your brain
consider important why is that an
important question to ask well we're
talking about good design because
whatever your brain considers important
that's what you're gonna kind of be
working on well focusing on right and so
the question is with this particular
shape what do you find most
important do you find the curve in the
back maybe these curves in the front or
this point right here and if you're like
most people you identified this section
right here as the most important part of
this particular shape the takeaway here
and it's supported by research is that
sharp corners are considered salient in
other words we in naturally infer that
they are important when we look at them
and if we do sharp corners and they're
not really important then we're kind of
like well I'm not sure what's going on
and there's a little bit of confusion
Hollow versus versus filled so this
question comes up which is better
a hollow button or a filled button and I
start going through all the way
different ways we can evaluate this for
example how many pixels are visible
excluding the text and with the hollow
button we've got about a thousand pixels
and with the filled we've got about ten
thousand okay how many shapes do we have
to process well for the hollow there too
you've got this kind of outer rectangle
and an interact at all you could argue
that both of those have to be processed
and with the field you've only got one
like that you could also argue well wait
maybe such shapes maybe it's just
corners how many corners do they have
well the hollows got eight because this
and this are both corners and at some
level we're processing this inside of
our - right
and if we're processing it then you can
argue cognitive load is a little bit
higher whereas the fields only got four
corners peripheral image and this is
actually be most important in my opinion
what if not the most important the
second most important criteria what does
this look like when you're not looking
at it and here the peripheral image kind
of looks like this because we don't have
acute sharp vision in our peripheral
vision the field looks like this so we
can still see it identify it as a button
from my perspective the one on the right
is more desirable especially for an
important button that leads me on the
path to something critical that I'm
designing the user interface for for
example I might be designing the user
interface
for a website and clicking this button
means more sales or more registrations
or more signups graphical message here
is that the border is important whereas
here the button is important so from my
perspective filled wins all the way
across the board all the way across
these different ways of evaluating so
the question of hollow versus filled the
answer is filled so my conclusions are
based on this research is that when you
have a choice between a hollow button or
a filled button the filled is the is the
better choice if you the only exception
to this I'm gonna stay on this for a
second the only exception this is for a
path that you maybe don't want the
customer to take for example a cancel
button right or the less likely path you
might do something different or you
might make it less without saturation
for example but in general I would
always go with a fill button and I'd use
saturation like we've gotten over here
in this example on the right and maybe
no saturation or a lower level of
saturation for the less desired path
corners again round corners are better
because we corners are salient and so we
don't want to call attention to the
corners we don't when a button that says
the corners of this button are are
important we want a button that says the
button is important and then with the
colored example that we saw before not
only do we not not only do we might have
a border that's thin and low contrast
but we also want to have a borders that
are rounded except for where we're
pointing because where we're pointing is
important
that's the salient piece of this whole
example and so the better call out
example is on the right so corner
sharpness needs to match the importance
right wrapping up so I grabbed this
example found this out there in the
internet and
and there are a number of issues with
this that are that can be fixed and we
talked about some of them here in this
session but one of the biggest issues is
that of contrast we have text that is
low contrast on we have essentially
white text on a light background and
it's hard to read it's maybe not so
obvious when you look at it the first
time but when you go back and you look
at the rules and you come back and look
at this you know and or if you look at a
side-by-side of something that's
essentially the same interface but
redesigned using the guidelines you can
start to see okay I'm getting it right
I'm getting to see that the one on the
right is far more easy to consume the
data in than the one on the left right
and so there are these are some of the
guidelines like I said this is a very
fast condensed course there's more out
there which I'll tell you about in a
little bit I want to summarize
everything we've talked about though up
to this point what we've learned every
on-screen element is information but not
every element is equally important right
so understanding and taking a moment to
ask the question what are the most
important pixels on screen or dots of
ink into the presentation and and what
are what are the most important and what
are the least the the ones of lower
importance emphasis should match
elements importance for readability we
need sufficient contrast on the
perceived brightness spectrum that means
black and white physical proximity
should match contextual proximity that
means friends should be close and
enemies should be enemies of the friends
should be kept far apart borders should
be thin and or low contrast and no
closer and as a guideline than 1.5 times
the space space with and you can break
that guideline if you go super low
contrast on the border or you make it
super thin get it closer if you need to
buttons should be filled and unimportant
buttons can be filled but with a lower
contrast against the background should
be round except for important corners
can be sharp where can I learn more
there's a website out there called s GUI
comm it stands for science of great UI
that's a site I've got out there it's
mine and I've got a free course out
there that you can sign up for by email
to learn more also if you go to dev IQ
comm you can get the full-on science of
great UI course and we've got a free
offer for connect conference viewers
courtesy of DevExpress everybody who's
watching and goes to this URL between
now and tomorrow night the 26th of
September at midnight GMT can get a free
copy of the product I work on code rush
if your work in Visual Studio this may
be of you steel and with that I believe
I'm done and you can we can answer
questions I think not only myself but
everyone included was learning lots of
things about UI which we get to we don't
get to think about it every day so
really cool some people were asking
about if you're gonna share your slides
they want to share with students and
things like that so are you gonna close
this somewhere I am NOT going to do that
I have like a suggested instead going to
the SGI comm you can get material there
and sometimes I'll give away a PDF at
conferences I'm gonna be speaking at dev
intersection coming up I've got a like a
full day workshop I think there may be
and I know I've got three courses there
as well and so people can come to those
as well if they want to get those those
PDFs that I give away oh well but people
will be able to watch this video on
YouTube at channel 9 later so they can
certainly do that alright thank you so
much for joining us and it was really a
great talk all right thank you